Samuel Leeds is one of Britain's most
successful property entrepreneurs a
high-flying investor are fast selling
author and founder of a leading property
education company
Samuel is recognized as one of the
brightest young stars in British
business
following his meteoric rise to success
by becoming a multi-millionaire in his
twenties
Samuel is in the elite echelons of UK
property investors over the next five
weeks 13 burning property entrepreneurs
will be battling it out to prove that
they are the ultimate property investor
the prize swen
pounds of Samuels cold hard cash to
kick-start one candidates property
journey this is the eviction
[Music]
previously on the eviction of 2,000
pounds and she needs to go up whether we
win or lose I would be majorly
disappointed and I would be pulling out
that makes more force [ __ ] so I'm
really very disappointed in this it's
really messed up so I'd say you're
evicted please leave just think you're
addicted please with did not give me a
good reason why you shouldn't be evicted
so we regret
[Music]
[Music]
good morning and welcome to the third
challenge up until this point you have
been completely spoon-fed the properties
have been secured by me that you've had
to refer the investors that you've sold
deals to have been put in place by me
things are about to change now and
you're not going to be spoon-fed and
things are about to get a lot lot harder
and more challenging most of the
successful companies in the world know
that to profit from something that I
have to own it but rather they can just
control it that's why Oba don't own
their taxis
that's why Amazon don't own most of
their stock they control it
Airbnb their own most of their
accommodation as a property entrepreneur
you can make significant amount of money
without owning property when you know
how to control it so in this challenge
you'll have to find and secure a
no-money-down
property deal that you have complete
control over which is going to be making
you a profit this can be a rent to rent
deal or at least option agreement
property the team who secures a deal
with no money that is the most
profitable deal will be the winning team
from this challenge at least three of
you will be evicted so you have three
days to find and secure a no-money-down
deal the teams are a little unbalanced
at the moment because we have three on
this side and five on this side so to
even things out we're going to move
somebody over Ricky you were the
previous team leader so I'm going to
give you five seconds to tell me who is
the weakest link on this team that you
do not want to work with anymore and
we'll send them over go
Alicia so you have three days I look
forward to seeing you in the boardroom
that's part of this challenge
you cannot tap in to any of your
existing contacts you'll be starting
again from scratch good luck
off you go so the guys have 72 hours to
secure a property with none of their own
money let's have a listen to Russell and
Alice there to see how it's done option
agreement is very similar to when you
buy a car on hire purchase so you take
over the car you pay for it monthly for
a few years and then after a few years
you have the option to buy the car or
you can just hand it back with a lease
option agreement it is exactly the same
you take over the mortgage payments you
have the option a few years later to buy
it or you can give it the landlord back
the challenge is finding an owner that
will allow you to buy their property in
this way so I rent to rent property is
where you have a public on the market
for rent you agree with the landlord to
take on a spatial contract where it
allows you to rent that popped out
creatively you could rent it out as HM
or you could rent out on service
accommodation ultimately it's a very low
entry to properties you don't have to
put massive deposits then typically
probably the first month's rent very
profitable and very easy and creative to
find Panos team captain yeah you call
that yeah okay I think we need to decide
what we want to do over the next three
days and what we're gonna target and
what we're going to do because if you go
rent to rent you can go down so many
different avenues and you can do loads
of different things I think the best
thing with the other task was the fact
that we had a plan we talked about that
plan for now I'm gonna catch that plan
for three days that's why we won yeah so
we need to throughout what we want to do
now in terms like lease options I think
if we get lease option we'd win this
we'd win this yeah
but getting a lease option is really
hard we will kind of know that I mean
I've tried a little bit I know you've
tried to know that you were to go at
lease options yeah they've taken a
little bit of work the way I envisioned
see in this task is one person should
attack making calls trying to get
viewings release options and then the
other three should do as
si yeah as the rents around off-ship I
don't know because I think we can be
renter at nature now but the difficulty
with that is if and last we go direct to
landlord and we get a really decent one
the return on the investment or the cash
flow is gonna be no real difference to a
decent si Hana's crew start finding
properties online which they can arrange
viewings on and the landlord and the
house and with them yes and who we going
to me guy called Alex so he's just
before of your group of friends you
thought well we're all individual
investors and we're working together on
some projects at the minute
Moorhead's and what's the kind of the
business model with you kind of think
I'll be to sort by team or taking it on
and then renter and yeah so with that
basically what we do is we take on
properties from landlords or
the well it's mainly landlords who just
you know want to keep the property
becomes appreciation and things like
that
we give them a guaranteed rent and then
look after maintenance tenants things
like that okay so it just means it's
less headache for them and we would come
along they look well paid
rather they're paying at the moment that
you get anyway and then like we said we
we did what we would do
I mean I know you said you like to be
hands-on stuff would you would you have
an issue with that or no okay so you're
quite open to the idea yeah probably if
we're gonna be getting what we will be
getting yes we have one less house to
worry about that's what you get just for
the up spell or something like in that
vicinity I'm worried because I think we
can get an essay but I think to win the
task we need a lease option yeah I agree
I think these lease options have got the
upper hand over rent already just
because you've got the option to buy at
the end so you get the capital growth
that technically the team head to a
local networking event in Derby to try
and find some more deals you know we
thought we're not gonna waste our time
today we need the lease option deals we
did no money down deals we need rent to
rent deals so we went in hard like
freaking networks the car park we didn't
even have the money to get in there
we've lagged the way we managed to blog
our way in to get into the event this
evening which was awesome and literally
we just cased the joint so day one of
lease option challenge or no money down
deal challenge and we may have secured a
deal fingers crossed
go team Hannah over with Alicia's team
the guys are all staring aimlessly at
their laptop seeing who can find the
funniest online cat videos River say
yeah I'm cool to be the team leader I
have a problem with it awesome decided I
love it is that cool with everyone yeah
okay alright so this is long let's just
dig in I don't have a plan I'm team
leader of our team so we've basically
chosen an area
now we're just hammering it out right
now to schedule appointments for
tomorrow to go out all right that joke
I'm looking for some properties in the
centre of Manchester looking for either
houses or apartments there are two beds
or more do you have any on your books
like that so I know that I've been in
the losing team twice many person here
to have done that but this challenge is
different because it really plays to my
strengths in terms of finding deals this
is the bread and butter of what property
investors and entrepreneurs do and it's
something I think I'm very good at okay
would it be possible for us to provide
an agreement that was drawn up by a
solicitor and then it was it was done
through yourselves but to the landlord
okay okay nobody turn up oh yeah we
should not right now go in the morning
but the master is like wow so you but
time you get you you left this I like so
ever get there your premise there yes
just wash out have a little nose yeah
liver seven yes right I mean every now
that is the worst motorway in this
country do you know if the lack of would
be right it'll be something so tie with
or okay okay cool
yeah that's great yeah good update
what's wrong with people
perfect yeah anyway at the start of day
two with the bombardment of viewings to
see in properties to secure Antony Leeds
Hannah's team on the hunt for those
elusive no money down deals Phil
his number apparently is that his house
out till Easter next year but now we may
have some others coming up so we're
touching base he's an older gentleman so
a hard sell won't go down well oh hi
Phil my name is Ricky and I believe on
the call I just got your number of a
gentleman called Oliver and yes we're
just yeah no problem
after 20 years in the business I just
want to relax still hold the properties
yeah
I'm either going to sell them in the
future or read them probably in an
arrangement like yours yeah you take on
that how many properties do you have
well now with the one that come on it'll
be now nine I'm sorry eight okay once I
sold this would be eight I'm really
passionate about property and I'm really
passionate about and working in helping
people like yourself so you know I'm
more than happy to travel a bit and it
works for everyone then it's great after
trying to secure some deals on the move
the Lots finally arrived in their first
viewing which is an absolute Doss all in
stoke-on-trent we just have a chapter
nine are some things not roll as long as
you're happy and we're happy and make
sure everything's good the first initial
thoughts are tread carefully Ricky this
guy is absolutely hench nine News
it's been no tenants in here for the
last two years
tenants from Austria last few years okay
how quickiy looking to move up do you
need the money now or you don't need the
mind out nurse okay cool okay look
around and see what we can do in how we
can help you and yeah we're Adams kind
of see what he's doing he's what was our
there's no don't see it they seem quite
dry if you dry this is this out here
looks real bad Wow I mean would you want
to go see the fuse box Jesus this place
is absolutely disgusting why is there
two things in here in all seriousness it
needs the Wolves need replastering
decoration painting new bar from new
toilets all of that needs taken out and
replacing up here we can we'll be able
to get rid of this make this into a nice
bedroom
I haven't spotted any major damage and I
could get this done easily for a
thousand pounds the top half sora and
everything you know
this is the ounce as it is it's having a
wee ting on within a couple of years
it's a mid terrace it's not a LAN
Terrace so it's obviously you just get a
bit out and a bit of flakiness but at
the end of the day it's not that bad
look it was the property was a dump is
they got the guy
I'd only knew what he was talking about
the southern seriously structurally
wrong there you've got the problems with
the boiler savoie the toilet was happy
it's a full refund
guys I know he said he'd be interested
in our lease option agreement the idea
of lease options is the low money down
that's not a little money down deal and
I mean I offered him 30 grand for the
house and he turned that down so I don't
think you're gonna get anywhere I think
the guys probably a little bit full of
it me you mean though he's got lots and
lots of houses and but he didn't know
basics about property and I think he's a
bit of a blogger and he's that's
probably his own house he's got so I
think brush yourself off move on find
the next and forget it forget about it
it's not gonna happen it's on 425
if we can get it for just the monthly
mortgage payments being covered and in
five years we'll give them a hundred and
thirty five and we'll pay for a light
refurb
the next viewer for Hannah and Co is a
cozy tuber terraced house in works worth
hello
nice to meet you Ricky that's me how are
you right on collectively collectively
work group of property investors and
we've come together we've got a company
and we're looking to invest in the area
I mean what about letting this place out
no no and is there any reason why
default the money to me well got the
money to pretty much dead in the water
then in it Ricky I think you've had
enough of 120 which is it kind of lowest
you'll go where I'm at at the minute and
I I would put an offering today but it
it would it would be below 120 so I
don't offend you it would be below 120
so yeah good point offering today will
be below 120 though or you're asking for
125 I would buy it off you for 135 but
in five years time and over that five
year is I would take over the property
I'd control it if you don't mum your
class you're kind of a not about your
income anything just financial Chris
about the mortgage would that be okay
what how much are the what's the amount
of the monthly mortgage payments 190 so
I'd buy it in five years I you're asking
for 135
I'll give you 135 in five years time I'd
control the property I take over you
would still be the landlord for the five
years but I would play the the mortgage
payments for you and it would be off
your hands still in your name we take
control of it you'd have to deal with it
we'll look after it and then in five
years I have the option to buy it for
hundred thirty five thousand so I'll
give you an extra 10 grand
the does that sound any interesting to
you what we still living it we won't
live in it we you we would want to
refurb it and come on Ricky spit it out
it would possibly rent it out you
wouldn't be able to live in it it would
basically be after we have to bring ten
centimeters so we would have to draw the
property and rent it out
well it did kind of make sense see how
much money would you want from us if we
paid the mortgage okay and you could if
we paid the mortgage for you and you
could move on how much money would you
want from us on a monthly basis as well
as the extra 10 grand for you guys to be
happy with it
oh I'll have to look good too yeah sure
you know you know yeah well I have a
think about it as I said I can buy it
today but it would be below 120,000 I
said think about a sweet your wife and
Prince what the one outright what is
what would you mean sorry if you wanted
to buy it
Oh if we wanted to buy it right now
would you like me to give you a figure
say one to five the refurb if I were to
buy it today
I could I could give you it would be
about between 105 and 110 thousand
that's what I could do today but I know
you've said no 220 so Marva proposal is
I could buy it for between 105 nine and
ten today or in five years time we take
control do the refurb and I'll give you
an extra 10 grand in five years this is
your chance Ricky your moment of a
lifetime please say something really
profound something from the ether
something so magnificent this man will
sign his signature on your ass cheek
with him Hannah and Anthony go and check
out one of three service departments
which could be used as corporate let's
to generate a monthly revenue
I know it's really really nice it's
lovely did you do all the lampshades
yourself I'm yeah I really like them
we're really impressed with the area
aren't we and the stand of the apartment
is really high-end I guess the easiest
way to explain is it's like a normal
tenancy in the sense that like she said
they manage us they put your best
interest we've got your best interest
but obviously you know Patricia manages
it for you it's just that the company is
the tenant instead seriously that
beautiful beautiful or not have we got a
deal
we've got a deal we just need to
negotiate the deposit the three
apartments the three apartments are
asked and they are perfect prime essays
they were honestly they would rent out
and you'll do really really well from
them one of them's furnished who aren't
furnished and they're all two bedrooms
you can get six percent occupancy the
slap-bang right near the city centre the
only only point is that she's a bit
worried about the deposit now I spoke to
her manager and I said look if we take
all three we do no deposit and she said
we might be able to wangle it but the
only sticking point is there's three
different landlords yeah what's the what
kind of cash flow looking at ease in
terms of the nightly rate the nightly
rate in Derby ranges from 85 - when I
was looking eighty five to a hundred
weekday and then it will go up to wait
how much does a rent for 75% opens array
yeah but it sounds very good
the returns can be good because your
occupancy is six people that's right so
what we could do what we could do find
someone that's willing to put deposit in
and we give them a return every month a
small cut of what we're getting to give
them back their deposit and a bit more
if the strongest deal
I know we've not run the numbers yet but
statistically it would be your four
apartments
turning them into essays because that's
a that's a that's four five yeah so
we'll make we'll make the most capital
appreciation and we'll make the most
cash flow so that'll have the biggest
ROI right at the close of play on
they to Hannah Anthony and John visited
a Midlands based mortgage broker they've
spoken to on the phone about lease
options unfortunately we weren't allowed
to film after a 90 minute meeting they
emerge from the building grinning like a
Cheshire bloody cats so basically we
went in there there was five apartments
okay not ten there's five departments we
went in there trying to Melton Court
which is right by Darby in Darby which
is right by the university what are they
they're 2-bedroom apartments fully
furnished seven nine five per calendar
month seven nine five per calendar month
you yeah so we went in there to try and
secure them and basically what we've
come out with is a potential lease
option to buy them in three years we've
also come out with a potential to buy
two hotels and a brewery 20 apartment
blocks in Sunderland that are currently
77 grands but the true value is 120 and
a guy in the next in the next few months
that's selling his portfolio and Darby
of 300 properties seriously seriously
everything she's got he's off market so
everything she showed us is completely
off market yeah and she just kept
showing us and showing us that all that
will be used for four years old I'll
send you that one so a massive turnoff
for Hanna's team if they can get the
deal over the line meanwhile Elisha
seemed headed to day two on the prowl
for securing their own no money down
deals and release to us
and I'm not today
it's time not to do
[Music]
it's an outside that third letting agent
for a stage this one does sales
analytics the plan here is to get in and
will every looking for these options
again and if not well we'll talk about
red threads as well she's really looking
for an army down hill here must be to
every estate agent a stoker pre-emptive
so while James an added Becca like a
parrot sweaty old pensioners Alicia and
Courtney cross the border to the
wonderful north of England hope it's a
pick up a bargain ensue drizzly
Manchester if there are no no license
yeah rented homes in that area despite
lease options being the most lucrative
of the two no money down strategies
Alicia and Courtney try and secure some
new luxury flats to use a serviced
accommodation
as a slow progressive in
okay keep shopping
not really good make sense for company I
think we need to clarify some of the
rules about if there's money involved in
the deal a normally down Deal challenge
it's always going to be some money
required to a certain extent with a
lease option agreement or events to rent
whether that's refurnishing redefining
contracts contracts and listen to fees
and things like that this is the
property down here oh no no no this is
working people thank you this property
used to generate around about 30 and a
half to fourteen thousand pound rent per
annum as an item oh yes
sharing more rooms yeah it has a Florida
license so single people yeah yeah I
mean I think it's a fire door sir we
spoke on the phone what we're looking to
do yeah so it sort of rent it for maybe
like five years somewhere between three
and seven typically for an agreed amount
yeah maybe
typically two around the single that
value or maybe enough to cover the
mortgage in there yeah and their
insurances and things like that agree
the price now I think you said this one
was on the market for one one nine was
it yes I think so
so we could agree from like 130 say or
something like that we can agree that
today plus their monthly payments until
the time we take over control the
property we cover all the maintenance
the management everything like that and
then rent the property out well this one
would be as an HMO yes so basically what
happens if the property wasn't on the
mortgage so he'll say then we would just
agree a monthly amount yeah
what do you think if this was done up
yeah what do you think you could get per
room on this property if it was done up
you're looking at around about anything
between I'll say between 75 to 95 per
room it's a big house it's an old shop
from this to there yeah okay write it
here
find or closer lock nice good-sized room
it does it come with a cap yeah that's
definitely a selling point
hello I love it I love it nights it's a
big it's a big space you've got proper
windows up here have to get a check I'm
pretty certain then this would have had
all the right planning and building regs
to have had it done it's closer to the
hospital so you get like nurses you know
you you'll you won't get these
properties especially in this area you
won't get a vacant property or a vacant
room yeah that's exactly belong to here
it's literally a stone's throw away from
the University yeah five ten minutes
from the hospital Wow so good area good
area good property open - sorry
I've written some creative practicing
after seeing a couple of potential deals
with the estate aja Pasha Abbey and
James build rapport by discussing some
non bias cultural observations with
their new mates but your we need the
vendor ideally to say yes on the phone
yeah if they can do that or if they can
either and we can shape yeah I can we
would need proof of that even if it's an
email yeah that would be okay got a
[ __ ] lease is the first one ever done
room I have to oh my gosh I've got two
more tomorrow not reviewed yet no rent
to rent this is like the best job ever
this is so worthwhile spending time you
stoke oh my gosh love I never thought
I'd say that by the Musto let's go back
to the castle let's tell the girls
the face is gonna be awesome hmm
this is not even a single with a line
and it's potentially being envied at the
moment but it's on the market for 19
insane I mean we've got to do the full
numbers on the valuation but initial
thoughts it's worth about what 40 would
say yeah right
and it's on the market for one one nine
that's twenty one thousand pound BMV
they're happy to rent it office maybe on
a single out basis I'd like 5 600 plan a
month we contain 2 a 5 bed HMO it has
fire doors in place it's being refurbed
like they were doing they're going to
repaint the entire house it's in good
Nick it's in a good area the agent
himself said that he can manage it and
you can get about 375 400 pound a room
out of that we were probably gonna make
like 800 plan a month from the property
and we can buy it and it's BMV and we
can buy five years time mate is like and
now let me ask you some more this is the
most fun oak I went to see three
properties you install them yes so we
arranged to meet him at the first
property at 4 o'clock and then we drove
up and saw two more on a different
Street and with him and then we went
back to his office to discuss kind of
figures how it's gonna work how the
deals all work and basically all three
are potential lease options which can be
used as hit remembers these spoke as the
vendors and said this is not going to do
blow my buy off you in like five or
seven years time gonna pay your monthly
amount doesn't we can do it no like yep
great so we're gonna get all this like
obviously filmed and time your handshake
agreements tomorrow but specific number
we've actually got em viewings tomorrow
at half 11 for two more shall be a lease
option yeah one of the 14 bed ones a
seven
and the best former you seriously the
best all becoming is the easiest is it's
a five bed then reefer be it yeah now it
usually has fire doors it like it used
to be licensed it's really close like
the Union stuff laid it's a perfect
eight you know really easy
it's like 20k BMV is the asking price so
we can secure a price today which is BMV
not ready now and we can run it and find
it it's going to open for you a lot of
agents we're telling us that actually
starts not good for what we were saying
about lease options because Nanako
properties have been on for very long
there were something really quickly like
what yeah yeah that's what we had today
so we've ended up having fire that's
crazy
there's always something anywhere yeah
after a good few hours kept in a hearty
breakfast the team's move on to day
three of the challenge with all of the
deals for both teams only proverbially
agreed can either team secure the
properties in time for the 5:00 p.m.
deadline get one minimum and three is
the absolute best we you know we'd be
very happy with that I just think we're
very key to to secure these like I said
we're not me Darby we're leaving this
afternoon so and if we could get this
sort of wrapped up and sorted out the
next few hours we will really really
appreciate that
Hana's team heads to everyone's favorite
portuguese chicken shops are secured
their first serviced accommodation deal
but are they perilously close to losing
it a stick
it's not good I know we've only got two
apartments CB grace so we didn't get the
one with the lamb yesterday but the guy
with the furniture is gonna give it to
us and the other one is going to give it
to us there's slightly different deals
they both want the posits but one go
away around now John pimps out the deals
on Facebook groups to try and find an
investor who can input the two thousand
pound they need to secure a deposit for
the rental essays JB opportunity after
getting a speedy response to his post
John gets some prep from Ricky on how to
close the deal over the phone if you
decide that and in the meantime we'll
send you the bank details transfer to
downtown higher k-th John ray balls your
art hello so what I'll do is I'll send
it ahead to turns over and then
obviously I'll give you the details of
the bank account and stuff I was
assuming we can sort it out good well we
were able to sort it out fairly quickly
so that we can email the agents your
today yeah of course yeah Antony takes a
call from the mortgage broker about the
potentially huge deal they have on the
table for five apartments in the center
of Darby
so in principle if we we offered 750
then we didn't affect basically get the
deal but we would just need to confirm
and check on it yeah excellent
fantastic Lisa brilliant to speak to you
and we will be in touch shortly
when you agreed 750 in terms of we need
to check what house prices are and
whether they're going up like a okay can
we just can we just take a second to
appreciate which take a secretary shape
we've just secured five apartments on a
lease option agreement in two days come
on crazy that is absolutely fine no
we're gonna come out of it just be
hammering these ultimate but note like
wow and translate something seriously
what deals no avoid oh no it's not it's
not it's not know what billion is
everybody has worked extremely hard and
I just wanted to clarify that with on a
phone and just get that sort of in
principle because that is amazing go
team go
please come in yes wait wait let's see
that squid let's come in buddy
ready rub my hands with my palms
enormous let me just recap this know we
started off yesterday securing the lease
option agreement on housing crew not the
best housing crew you know um it
required to support a minimum of ten
thousand pound into it
however the option to purchase it you
know we think they probably make around
twenty five thousand pounds
well we purchased it in the five years
and for the term we would make three
hundred pound a month on the apartment
everyone for five years yeah
we then went on to secure a red to red
HMO in stoke-on-trent we're going to do
a light refurbishment on the property of
two thousand pounds and it was going to
make us two hundred and forty pounds
every month yeah that's the return on
investment of one hundred and thirty two
percent seed fantastic yeah we then went
on to secure two apartments in dolly yep
the are making us an infinite return on
investment we require two thousand
pounds to get into the deal which we use
we ended up getting six thousand we only
look at 6000 pounds instead of the two
thousand pounds so John I've got one
look two thousand back we end up
securing eight thousand one I look
$2,000 for map sixty one thousand guy so
we secured eight thousand pounds in
about 25 minutes that's meant order to
secure these apartments these apartments
are going to make us just under a
thousand pounds every month which gives
us a return on investment of what it's
an infinite return on investment but it
gives us fifty nine thousand pounds over
the term
three-year term absolutely amazing
I told you what told you I'd make me
another just ask all the wire
Lisa causes often says guys look he's
happy with the proposal we can't take it
at 600,000 what does he want
so he says 750 thousand pounds to take
the five departments on a three-year
lease option agreement how much is that
necklace at this moment in time he's
what he saw the properties to us for 750
grand okay yeah in three years time okay
at the Mystics there were five hundred
and seventy one thousand yep so if if we
go once everyone voice saying on that
let's just go
171 172 173 174 bit of 105,000 pounds
today how I got him however so I just
think that's just thank you see however
history shows how prices go up the
dollar at a time
southern in the next five years they're
gonna dollar how much we think legally
walk why say they're worth 200,000 how
much do we like then do this do numbers
get the top layer on these three years
members three years okay
three is what they know they were going
to actually conservatively just so they
would look good 90 so 390 so it's quite
a bit a beauty
so ok guys from nothing to potential
three in two days some you needs is the
Bob Senate wait well there you have it
three hundred thousand pounds in pure
profit generated from nothing in only 72
hours Hanna's team have played an
absolute blinder but I feel like out of
nothing but common courtesy we should go
and see how Alicia's team finished day
three of the task to win this challenge
they are probably going to have to
either rob a bank or come up with a cure
for cancer it's empty you can't live in
a house where you need to rewire it the
boy doesn't work we have no idea we'll
find out so I see pastor Lee thank you
so much we went shall we shall you know
you're a new intern still thanks
all right we got two we get three get
figures that's crazy
now we need to be right let's get these
figures done all right so yeah this room
will not count
there's not a file on the night which is
in this pre-new so an emergency line
which is good I don't think you can no
no I'm in first the house is a good
thing yeah it's a good storage space if
don't sorry - very good size
very good size okay
I need sake nope we'll be able to walk
you down I'm dealing with DC what I need
actually actually you know I was gonna
go away for three months
yeah but I was gonna give the DS to
somebody because I don't want to deal
with this yeah and because I have to be
all the time do it with the council so
somebody needs
so I already agreed with somebody part
of it too that you know he's going to
take you down right he's gonna you know
just give me a fixer interval take over
control of the property so from when we
agree on and if there's a turnin time
everything's our responsibility
animation well you take the tenants
always 100% yeah if it's got tenants in
I'd rather he will claim justice in that
then I'll be interesting because I'm I'm
gonna go away for three months so I
don't want the headache
granny lazy in sobriety are you saying
that you know after five years you
can't decide not to buy it yeah
and that can't really happen because
that's like you're trying to go into a
deal try and get a good deal but you
want the cake and eat it yourself yeah
yeah which in the real world it is
always like that yeah yeah so after five
years there has to be a commitment 100%
of buying it okay okay if we gave our
intent after three to sorry so after
three years yeah we gave our intent so
he has two years there yeah so after
three years what would you like to do so
it's a five year as we do okay five
years yeah yeah but after three years or
three years into the five years we have
to give our antenna so I don't want to
buy a lot so he knows we have to give
Rincon so you wanted you you want to
lease it for three years hundred percent
but after the three years you want to
give an answer whether you and Hawaii or
not yeah I've spoken to him and after a
detailed conversation he said he would
accept 850-pound hundred a month
I'm very happy with that I and he seems
happy enough with the option to don't
film that I didn't try to get him down
more let him do the news yeah he knows
Alicia's team is a high-end fast food
restaurant in order to put together
their presentation package for Samuel
with two lease option agreements in the
back even though the numbers may not be
as outstanding as Hannah's team
achieving all of this in only three days
from a completely standing start is
nothing short of stunning although my
job is to take the piss and make
everyone look stupid I have absolutely
nothing but respect for the work and
dedication
both teams are putting over this
challenge proving to anyone watching
getting property with none of your own
money is absolutely possible and now
back to my real job home deadlines
reached deals stacked but who will be
left hanging
in the boardroom so your challenge was
to find a free house a no-money-down
deal a lease option agreement or a rent
to rent and both teams succeeded which
is good
well they're reasonably impressed that
you both found a lease option agreement
I know you also found rent to rents
however there will be a losing team
there'll be a winning team and the
losing team at least three of you will
be evicted tonight Hannah your team the
figures were presented pretty terribly I
on a scruffy bit of paper scribbled down
why did you know you had quite a lot of
time to prepare that why did you not
present it in a more professional manner
to be honest to deal with secured 4:30
they share do you feel you've been a
good team leader maybe said we all work
together
you're quite decent I was a good team
leader what were you a good team leader
because I listened to everyone I invited
everyone's opinion and we work together
we worked as the team to decide what we
were gonna do where we were where we
were going to go but did you lead that
or did you all just care of it together
no we all put our input in and then from
that we made a decision as far as what
was ultimately going to happen and
Courtney I was speaking to the estate
agents I spoke to a couple when we went
to Manchester yesterday and it was quite
scary but I
like it's something that I have really
been very problem
yeah do you work in sales so you find it
scary phone as they attempt to be
working sales and Ricky you've proven
the numbers is not your strong point and
you've messed up in previous challenges
of numbers as that held as I held you
back in this challenge no I think what I
was negotiating ago she in this
challenge I knew my numbers were when we
were negotiating and most of the deals
the deals that were negotiated most of
them we they laugh with the numbers we
were happy I feel in this task I feel in
this task that John was the weakest link
did you not secure the deal okay so
basically it's 505 departments that we
manage this as for the lease option
agreement so five apartments are 795
calendar month and they're fully
furnished and the vendor wants 750,000
pounds to the five apartments after
three years so how much money will you
need to put down in terms of rent in the
apartment no just in terms of the whole
deal how much you actually made why not
well we need the one-pound to secure the
lease option but they haven't asked for
a deposit on it what about the legal
fees and stuff well the legal fees be
about a thousand pounds and in terms of
the actually warranty then a thousand
pounds but in terms of the actual deer
itself yeah money now so you'll just
need legal fees John you raised some
money what was that for that was another
deal which we did have to service
accommodations and then Darby's isn't
and it needed how much to put down we
needed two thousand pounds force of the
and when you respond to or for raising
the money yes and the how much money do
you have to race we need to raise two
thousand pounds and you might actually
get back use that in the bank yes very
good
okay I kind of feel like with Alicia's
team that it's not really Alicia's team
I kind of see it as a bezoar James's
team I don't think you've led this at
all who was who was the leader I was
while it was a very good description of
everything we all knew that we have
different strengths and different areas
so the deal that you brought to the
table which was a no-money-down deal
tiny little bit of money for legal fees
but you've clearly proven that you can
raise a few thousand pounds no problem
what do you feel about their numbers
guys seems you'll see suits and offers
right it seems pretty fair so it's a
normally done deal you'll be making very
good profit it's five apartments you you
the little money that you might need
you've demonstrated that you can raise
you've actually got two thousand pounds
already in the bank I think that's
that's very impressive
elation esteem your property again
you've secured multiple properties the
one that you put forward was a lease
option agreement capsule tax
calculations it's worked in with the
bills the bills for 7 min hmm does not
fully tented come in but winners
community so console.log so when it's
not fully effective is 400 baht on your
working Zack you've worked it out as if
it is fully tentative but then still put
the not fully attentive builder and the
council tax in the bay city it's not on
there anywhere
so that 115-pound that you're going to
make every month has been completely
wiped out but the fact that you've got
the council tax on them my thoughts on
all of this are we don't have a losing
team we have a winning team because you
completed the challenge and to be honest
I'm pretty shocked that you've both
managed to get several property deals
that are know me down rent to rent to
lease option agreements in that in the
time you've had I'm impressed
if any of you guys got lease option
agreement properties that you've secured
in in real life before this challenge so
the fact that
you've been in property for what six 12
months or so and none of you have got
any lease option agreement properties
and now within the last few days you've
managed to get lease option agreement no
money down went to rents it's quite it's
it's quite shocking really you've all
done great unfortunately three of you
are going to have to be evicted I think
you you've all been very strong you're
on the super winning team so you guys
are safe so you can go back to the
castle
enjoy yourselves we've got some treats
planned for you off you go Alicia's team
I don't think any of you are gonna leave
at this point a loser I think you've
done fantastically well but clearly
Hanna's team were superior so I'm gonna
give you guys a little bit of time to
work out who ultimately you think could
have poured their weight more because
unfortunately with regret three of you
will be leaving the castle tonight so
I'll give you a few minutes if you want
to head down to the back room so tonight
three of you are gonna have to be
evicted and go home you've done well in
your challenge but just not quite as
good as the other team this is just the
way the game is three of you're gonna
have to go so my question is what three
should I Vic to be evicted why is that
okay you're a big kid off you go and
they follow my example a good yeah
neither said a good leader follows by
example no no they lead by example and
others follow no apology no apology who
followed you we didn't we meet we
decided together too
pointman since i said okay let's choose
an area and then we all we all did some
research Abby did she lady I don't feel
like she left James did she laid so you
were the leader but you didn't lead are
they what should you be stained because
I have just shown that I am a good
leader you are a good leader whilst you
know letting people follow by example
and listen
true I had a bad experience in terms of
getting hot-headed right now two of you
are about to be evicted and one of these
going to put through to the semi-final
and only to be thinking I'm giving
20,000 pound of my own money to somebody
do I really want to give it to someone
who's a hothead who's arguing with
people I wouldn't then arguing with
people I had an argument with one person
in which we've all had a problem with
but I was the only one that shall they
said the issue I think we've all seen it
she was not argumentative I wish she had
her moments where she was kind of high
or low and yeah very high that's exactly
right you know you are they you know you
are they you're unpredictable that's
what you are what minute if you're in a
great mood things are fantastic if
you're in a bad mood everybody knows
you're unpredictable whereas James is a
bit more predictable my problem with
James is that he's been on the losing
challenge every single time yeah and I
keep saying I keep saying I'm waiting
I'm waiting James
I was out late knocking doors I was
overly we went out and we stayin Stoke
and I was the reason Danny won't last
challenge and you didn't was because
you're better at articulating yourself
and you wouldn't you win yourself over
and present in your case in the
boardroom now I just don't know
everything whether that's acceptable
that you can just keep talking every
every every time I the boardroom in I'll
have potential you know you just you
just talk magically way with your words
through to the next round it is a
secured deals but the bottom line is
you've been on the losing time every
challenge last challenge I said you
better show you potential and you better
win this and you haven't so it just puts
me if I say okay you can get through and
if it is too it's just it just doesn't
feel right
you're unpredictable but Alicia you
didn't lead I don't think you've got
what it takes to win this so with regret
you were evicted so here we are again
James I can't keep doing this you and
somebody else you and somebody else it's
the third time it's happened and to be
honest I'm really struggling I know
you've got potential but I can't keep
saying that every time well it's a tough
one I think you're both going to be very
successful in real life and I'm looking
forward to seeing your journeys however
James we I don't think we can keep
having this conversation again and again
so with regret you're evicted if you go
[Music]
Abbey you're gonna have to be a bit more
predictable and more stable I don't want
to hear you swearing at anybody
so in anybody I want to see you sound
minded but continue doing what you're
doing
off you go you know when you hear that
word it's crushing you know cuz you
don't want to leave the experiences are
really amazing but everyone has to have
an end so this is my end and that's
alright I've learned so much so I was
crushed but I'm really proud of the
journey that I've done I've come so far
since the first day I've been here and
to be honest it's not the end for me I'm
going home and I'm I'm feeling good
[Music]
next time on the eviction like you look
our bunny about it what's that all about
I think me to ponder this are gonna be
me and don't label
I'll be embarrassed to go up to someone
that they're going to give me 20,000
down and just say hey we're gonna make
stupid decisions like this I don't think
you need my money for that reason you
evicted
[Music]